[Music]
jack
hey i got another one for you all right
i'm ready
maybe i got more explaining to do you
explain it toto
lucy yeah so here it is so
what i like doing the point of these
explainer videos just
if it's not otherwise obvious is i want
to just
disentangle some things you might have
thought you knew
or thought you knew well but not well
enough were there's some nuance
to it and i just want to sort of pump
people's enlightenment regarding the
natural world around them
that's all i i i always like the little
plot twist in these
okay all right that's what's cool about
it okay
okay so today i want to talk about force
and pressure gotcha okay okay
so i'm not talking about sort of
emotional pressure
okay that's what i'm talking about right
right you know
my job has gotten me under so much
pressure i'm talking about physics
pressure and physics force all right
um by the way another way we use those
words in
everyday life we say um how much force
are you showing on the battlefield so
that's another
cultural usage of those two terms each
of those words
has a precise definition in physics
not to mention space force
yes that's in there too okay they don't
call it space pressure no there's a
space
force so a force is what you think it is
right you push on something
and you create a force that might set it
into motion
okay and if it's something that doesn't
move but it's still fragile you put
enough force on it you might break it
nice yeah okay so forces make things
happen
and when we say happen we mean something
changes about the object
typically it's set into motion and isaac
newton first wrote down an equation
about this okay he said
force equal equals the mass of the
object times the acceleration
it'll get if you put that force on that
object
that's it okay so you use that formula
you say well
here's an object i'm going to put a
certain amount of force and
it has to be like a net force so in
other words if you put a force
exactly opposite mind then the forces
cancel
and then there's no net force there's
nothing accelerates right
so if everything is in balance you can
have very high forces operating
but nothing's gonna happen right but if
there's a slight imbalance
then there will be motion and didn't
long ago we talk about this like at the
gym
why is it that the person spotting for
someone else
does not have to be as muscle bound as
the person lifting the weights
have you ever thought about that um
every time i go to the gym
okay somebody will say hey man give me a
spot and it's always a dude who's eight
times bigger than i am
and he's lifting on a building
he's actually lifting a building
i just stand there in case i drop it
right and he goes hey buddy
can you give me a spot and i'm just like
no
what am i supposed to do when you're
lifting like
and you're struggling you're not only
trying if you're struggling and there's
a point where you can't lift it anymore
you want me to come help you right you
want me to then take over
okay here's why that works okay
because if all forces are balanced
then any force will move it
no matter how small so watch what
happens so i'm there pump i'm on the
bench
bench just a bench press typically right
because the weight is above the person's
neck
right so this is dangerous you don't
need a spotter if you do a bent over
sort of rowing lift no because you could
just drop the weight just you just trump
that's no big deal when it's over your
windpipe it's like hey chuck can you
spot me and i'm like hey man
you want to die it's okay you get my
skinny ass to prevent you from dying
all right so watch so here i am i'm
lifting and that's getting harder and
harder
all right and now there's a point where
i get it half
way and i can't get it any further
and i say chuck help me out here
in that moment my upward force
equals the downward force of those
weights and right force on earth from
gravity is called your weight
so the weight equals the force pushing
up on it if they're equal
now the thing is just stopped moving
okay
it has stopped moving so now you come
along and say here you go
and then you lift and you lift you can
probably use one hand to do this
you lift it back up onto the rack
because the forces were balanced whereas
previously
the the person's force was greater than
the
weight of the weights right and so if
it's greater i'm in control here and i
can push the thing away from earth
away from earth's urges to try to bring
it back
when we're in balance then you break
that tie
basically and put it over the hump
that's why that works
that's very cool okay so we're team
we're teaming up
on the weights basically like you're
teaming up right and it doesn't make a
difference how strong i am i could take
two fingers and just
whatever little bit i'm doing now you're
provided
provided that he's not losing that
battle
okay if the weight is on its way down
you're gonna need
it's not balanced you have to counteract
that
right and then put in a little more to
get the thing back up to the
to the stack and that's when i stand
over top of him and go
sorry man you're going to die
you sound like this has happened before
all right so just to get a sense of what
forces are
okay that's and oh so with regard to
acceleration
if there's a net force then the object's
motion will continue to
increase in speed you have an
acceleration
all right so there you have it one last
thing just
in detail if all forces are balanced
it can still be in motion it just won't
be accelerating
all right okay so you can have no motion
or constant motion if there's a net
force it will accelerate
that's the point that's going on here
all right so
you're in your car and your foot is on
the accelerator pedal
and you're sticking to 60 miles an hour
55 miles an hour
well what does it mean if your foot is
on the accelerator pedal but you're not
increasing in speed you're not
accelerating
oh well the force the accelerator pedal
is trying to put in the car
is exactly balanced by the friction of
the tires on the road
and the air resistance all of that is
balanced
and you're maintaining constant speed if
you want to take it out of balance
you press the pedal even harder to
overcome that balance and now you can
pass the car on the right by
accelerating up to 70
you pass him and then you slow it back
down again right so that's what's
going on with force and everybody learns
this in like physics
101 the first 10 days
okay so now what is pressure
pressure is when you have been dating
for four years and she goes what are we
doing here
okay
seriously how many times can i take you
home for thanksgiving and explain to my
parents
that you know we're not ready yet what i
mean
okay so that's pressure you tell me
that's pressure
okay that's not the kind of pressure i'm
talking about okay okay okay
that's dating pressure how about that
right right so we're talking about
physics pressure so pressure
intimately needs force
to be what it is but it's not the same
thing
uh-oh okay okay it's not the same thing
so if you want to find out what it
is you got to look at the equation
for pressure okay okay have you ever
seen the equation of
pressure i don't think i have all right
let me before i get to that
let me tell you a few things that are
affected by pressure for example
uh your knife set how sharp are your
knives
that is all about pressure all about
pressure okay uh if you
are you gonna fall through the ice
on that pond as you walk across it
that's all about
pressure and stupidity let's do it
right
all right so let's talk about this here
you go
pressure is force
divided by area oh
okay and i didn't even know that
equation but that makes
perfect sense it makes perfect sense so
watch so watch
so if i'm walking out onto
a frozen pond and i don't want to fall
through if i have tiny itty-bitty ass
feet
then the area of the bottom of my feet
is small
but what happens if you have a small
number in the denominator of a fraction
the value of that goes higher right so
if pressure is forced
divided by area and that area gets
smaller and smaller
the pressure gets higher and you punch
through that ice
and you die you need clown shoes you
need clown shoes
[Laughter]
get the biggest ass shoes you can find
so that force is spread over the largest
area possible right so when you have a
big area
the force divided by a big area makes a
low pressure
and so with low pressure now you can get
across the ice
without sinking through you improves
your chances
of of of not breaking the ice this is
what snowshoes are
what what are snowshoes they're like the
the the the
you know the mountain man snow
equivalent of clown shoes
all right because that the snowshoe is
this big
it's a uh it's like a big net
and it attaches to the bottom of your
feet and when you walk on it
your body weight is now spread over a
larger
area and you don't plunge down through
deep snow
you still sink a little bit but not as
much as you would have and then you can
actually
walk have you ever seen the width
of the paws of a polar bear
they're huge oh my god it's like oh my
god because there's some big mofos and
they don't want to sink through the snow
okay they spend a lot of their time on
ice but this matters
okay and so
what about your knives when you go to
cut something you apply
a force how do you make that force as
effective as possible to cut
you want the lowest possible area
over which you're applying that force so
that you have the highest possible
pressure
okay you get pressure for free so when
you so what what what is a dull knife
you look at it under a microscope it's
it's a it's all chewed up it's flat
it's like so your pressure let's say you
put 10 pounds of pressure on it
is spread over this long area over the
length of the blade
and you try to cut something with it
with it and you mangle the food
you have to press even harder to get it
through
a perfectly sharpened blade what's the
area of a blade edge
tell me that the area of a of a
sharpened blade edge it is so tiny
that even the mildest force of that
knife
will cut through the food and that's why
chefs are always sharpened in their
knives
because they want to increase the
pressure on their food
because they don't want to have to
increase their force
to get the pressure they want they're
reducing the area
to get the pressure they want sweet
so this is this is force versus pressure
and uh i don't know how many people
internalize this feel it think about it
but
this distinction between force and
pressure manifests
everywhere everywhere
and by the way it's why a
tornado can explode your house
wow okay you say oh because the wind is
high here's what's happening
all right it's very low pressure in the
middle of a tornado
okay really really low pressure and
inside your house
you have slightly higher pressure than
that tornado
now suppose that pressure difference is
like
one pound per square inch difference
let's say
okay it might be a little high for this
example like a tenth of a pound per
square inch
i don't care a tenth of a pound okay
so inside the house the air has not
equilibrated with the outside of the
house yet the tornado comes
it sits on your house oh my gosh
every square inch of your wall
is feeling a tenth of a pound pressing
outward
so ten square inches feels how much a
hundred
no ten it's a tenth of a pound so ten
square inches is a pound
okay a hundred square inches is just 10
inches by 10 inches
that's 10 pounds right your wall is
probably bigger
than 10 inches by 10 inches square you
keep adding this
up and that pressure you get a thousand
pounds of pressure oh my god that's more
than the kool-aid guy
actually exerts exactly get through a
wall
to say oh yeah so what i didn't i didn't
say it right
so the the it's a thousands
of pounds of total
force right spread across that
wall but the whole wall is only built to
handle you leaning on it or
or or to hold up the house it's not
enough to prevent the tornado from
exploding
your house and all the walls blow out
take a look at
video footage of homes they don't
collapse
they're turned into matchsticks that's
matchsticks and they explode outwards
that is pressure at its most deadly
wow and so you know there you have it
now see this is what i'm talking about
when i say plot twist
no one would ever think that you just
talk about force and pressure and we end
up right here that's right and by the
way it's how bombs work what is a bomb
it sets a pressure wave
high temperature uh expansion of the air
because there's some like an explosion
is a very high
um temperature abrupt ins uh device
right but it happens
to happen rapidly so that it's like like
a bullet firing
it's a rapid expansion of gas which
shoves the bullet out but if it's a bomb
there's no bullet it's just the
expanding air right sometimes you can
put in shrapnel but air will do this
and the expanding air comes out and now
you have air pressure too high on one
side of the wall
versus the other and that'll blow the
wall inward rather than outward
or if the bomb is inside the house it'll
blow the house up instead of it
right so this is pressure on the wall
spread
over the area and by the way if all of
that force were in one spot
it would just puncture a hole through
the wall right that's so cool
oh my god so why can't we find a way
everybody's always trying to figure out
a way to predict
where a tornado will go which is almost
impossible
why not just have like a tornado
airbag well you would die
no it's going to say wait chuck chuck
wait chuck you don't need
tools to tell you where the freaking
tornado is just look
that's true you're trying to see airbags
exploding oh
there must be a tornado somewhere here
right yeah
exactly i'm over thinking you're
overthinking that one totally check
overthinking yeah okay chuck we're done
there that's pressure versus
uh force that's very cool not to mention
very very cool song under pressure
oh yeah yeah the uh queen yeah very good
very good
all right we gotta go okay good to have
you chuck tweeting at chuck nice comic i
follow you thank you
thank you all right i follow you too
we're done here i've been your host neil
degrasse tyson
you're a personal astrophysicist and as
always keep looking up
you